oregon's department of education is
encouraging teachers to register for
training
that encourages something called
ethnomathematics
ethnomathematics not making that up that
training teaches that white supremacy
manifests itself in the focus on finding
the right answer
answer to math problems algebra
is racist french revolution anyone
libby evans is a senior editor at the
post-millennial she joins us tonight
maybe this one
is one of those stories um it's hard to
believe it's real there are so many of
those
how could math be racist since it's
purely objective
well that's a really good question but
to answer that question you also have to
understand that objectivity
is now considered racist so
you know that's part of the problem
anything where you get to have right and
wrong answers
well you know that's racist but there
are several additional problems with
this entire program the first one is
that this is the idea that uh
teachers are perpetuating racism in the
classroom because they are racist
they are blind to their own biases and
they don't have any control over whether
or not they bring that racism with them
the other one is as you said this idea
that math is a
white discipline which even a modicum of
research would tell you
is monumentally absurd and the third is
this concept of the
the soft bigotry of lowered expectations
that tells people that
um students of color can't achieve to
the given standard and so those
standards need to be changed
but the problem of course is that kids
aren't stupid and
they know when they're being pandered to
they know when they're being
patted on the head and told that they're
doing a good job when they know
themselves that they're not measuring up
we also know that kids thrive when they
are held to account
any parent can tell you this when a
child is
expected to live up to a certain measure
of responsibility
kids are able to thrive with that they
they need that they need to be able to
take care of themselves
and to live up to standards any yeah any
kid knows this
um and so when we treat them like
they're idiots that they need to have
interpretive dance lessons in order to
learn math
they see right through that they
obviously they obviously do
so i don't know who's being fooled here
we're bankrupting our nation
uh we're bankrupting these kids lives
the schools are closed we're killing
them that way
um and we're also messing so much with
the language
we're we're accepting the terms of
leftist indoctrination
um we're accepting these terms
anti-racism there's no reason for us to
do this
they're not real they're not based in
reality and we're also
no you're right and we're pretending
that this is on the level when it's not
you've obviously you've obviously picked
up on that libby i appreciate you coming
on again tonight
it's good to see you thank you thanks so
much